mahut toulouse la dame a eu de palo oz
au cip
pour ghislain lebel entretenir une
pelouse c'est tout simplement une perte
de temps âgé de 72 ans cet agriculteur
cultive absolument chaque parcelle du
terrain qui entoure sa maison depuis
plus de 30 ans c'est un agriculteur ben
jemâa avec l'intuition un grand jardin
qu'ils cultivent seul tout simplement
par passion et désire d'autosuffisance
une activité essentielle pour sa santé
physique et mentale selon lui est grand
de personnes avaient besoin
à faire un milieu me ressourcer mardi
grande gislais le belle récolte le plus
possible ses propres semences
il cultive une trentaine de différentes
sortes de légumes et de fruits
tout ça sans produit ni engrais
chimiques il priorise les rotations de
cultures des engrais organiques les
engrais de minéraux naturels et les
engrais verts
[Musique]
quand très bons légumes sains ya tout
qui faute de main qui te porte les
caleçons longs baisers moment mais moi
je retire à fond
- d'un seul moyen pour moi comme que
j'ai ici c'est qu'ils manquent de ces
des minéraux un seul qui est malléable
énormément mais ça retient pas si mineo
ça capte les introuvables ou des
millions pour s'arrêter vers les anglais
je ne suis heureuse un budget qui me
sert d'abord dans des fours dessus de
travail et un coin de terre le cema
sarrazin puis a rendu à la saint jean
mais je le vire et puis leur jeu recèle
mon japonais honda a nourri la terre ça
amène beaucoup de magnésium et calcium
puis à la zot au sol c'est que les
religions surtout vélo
cet homme au pouce vert à un conseil
particulier à donner aux agriculteurs
amateurs beaucoup de patience ghislain
lebel ajoute qu'il est aussi important
que les gens ne se gêne pas pour
demander conseil aux agriculteurs plus
expérimentés qui les entoure et surtout
l'important selon lui c'est de suivre
ces patients
quand elle a quelque chose en trois
[Musique]
séquences assez veille
ça rentre en action jennyfer boudreau
radio-canada rimouski ici bas saint
laurent